uh Saturday night Trump rally in Warren
Michigan in support of Tudor Dixon and a
number of other Republican candidates
Trump dripping wet afraid we already
talked about that part let's look at
some video of the people who said I'm
gonna go to this rally here is a woman
who claims to teach economics I don't
know where her PhD in economics is from
or anything and she says she's telling
her students and again we don't know
where this is happening to buy gold and
silver
and so I just really do my best in
regards to teaching them about economics
showing them the value talking about
silver and gold and precious metals
versus investing in the stock market no
supply and demand curves none of that
stuff uh gold coins because I say at the
end of
the end of the value that you can take
home
probably one of the most cited economic
scholars in the world and it's just my
ignorance where I have not heard of this
woman again unclear where she's teaching
economics there was a guy at the Trump
rally who it's whenever they mention
anyone who's gay like there's a comment
about Marjorie Taylor green mentioned
people that judge and she just can't
avoid a homophobic comment when she
mentions a gay person here is a guy who
mentions mentions Anderson Cooper and
again like makes just a weird homophobic
comment first Prime Minister in a
Catholic hardcore country and she won
with that much Landslide where is all of
them to be happy with it right nothing
zero zip silent CNN they don't say
anything and what's his name Anderson
Cooper he is a gay he's supposed to
support that no for women's rent
Anderson Cooper is a gay as this
individual points out and therefore
Anderson Cooper should like the new
radical neo-fascist prime minister of
Italy
because she's a woman and gay men like
women's rights quite a political
analysis from this gentleman really
interesting
um he also later was interviewed or
earlier who knows earlier later
um and said that it Jared kushner's
ability to solve problems is just
incredible
and remember Jared Kushner was assigned
by Trump to solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict and uh you
know we all know how that turned out one
woman that was interviewed by real
America's voice at the Trump rally over
the weekend
she threw herself at the mercy of the
audience apologizing because she used to
be on the left listen to this I wanted
to apologize to humanity for voting for
the Antichrist Obama I deeply apologize
I was also pro-choice and I was an
atheist until January 21st and now she
seems to have a cross that she's wearing
so she went from being an atheist to
being a Christian 2021 I had a sudden
Awakening it was it was absolutely crazy
so I went from Blue to Red to Maga and
I'm here and I absolutely love it well I
want to tell you you don't have anything
to apologize for uh we all make mistakes
in our life and and that's where God's
grace comes in right that's the biggest
thing for me it is oh my gosh that's
amazing right I wrote about it on my sub
stack she's got a sub stack oh beautiful
you would believe me except my husband
was there when it happened it it
happened so suddenly and so amazing and
it was almost like a stroke it happened
so quickly it was just like a switch was
turned off
memory stick was like stuck into my
brain and I just started preaching out
of nowhere it was the most insane thing
it sounds like it absolutely sounds like
it that's very interesting couple other
Clips here's some people at the Trump
rally with the so-called election
Integrity Force who are trying to sign
up so-called poll Challengers to
challenge votes and part of what we're
doing is
buses and courses trying to credential
as many poll Challengers as we can by
the way credential it's such a that
that's an interesting term for what
they're trying to do quite a credential
they get so are you signing up folks
though that if they want to be a poll
Challenger they can yes absolutely you
can go to mc4ei.com or
electionintegrityforce.com and sign up
to be a whole challenging volunteer we
are credentialing people all over the
state so you don't have to be here uh in
Macomb or it's quite a credentialing
body that this guy is doing okay and
then lastly here's a woman who loves
that the Republican candidate tutor
Dixon for governor in Michigan is
completely against all abortion this
woman loves it if she got
um uh a molested by a family member she
would keep her child and I'm right went
to it I would keep mine too so please do
not vote for tutor um give up on Twitter
because she's saying she does not want
abortions in Michigan's under no
exceptions I'm willing to um go even a
little bit extra and say that me and
Tudor we will have discussions and I
will be sitting with her and we will
make a way because this is the way we
will do Planned Parenthood should be
working vigorously and effortlessly for
those abortion laws not uh Tudor Dixon
they should get monies for these women
if abortions won't be in Michigan then
fly those women somewhere and get them
some help because no I do have sympathy
for people who's raped and incest but
Planned Parenthood should get monies and
send these women to another outside
State that's close Okay so I guess what
she's saying is
she's against any exceptions for rape
and incest but she's empathetic to
people to whom that happens
but fly them to a different state that's
very weird and extraordinarily scrambled
but it is what it is
scary stuff at the Trump rally and we
will have all of these clips on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show